いやホントにね俺まで今回はねもう本当にね俺が悪かった
もうほんとにでも完璧に銀行にはちゃんと今日行ってきっをしたからもうそれに前あの
出力を注いでしまってちょっとねえっ
はいあー
全部ない今
すいません許してくださいが悪かっ
ねじいちゃんの通帳カードレスで唯一を打つ通知お母さんに渡して来てるでしょ
ああああ枯れないぴょんブーッ
ううううううっねぇ
何問題今日の夜ご飯も損みたい大丈夫させ外販な
それはねますダメダメムチン上昇ダメヒッチハイク
その手軽な続く一回行ってみたかったそれは通帳もないもんね分かりましたすいません
本当にそれはもうちょいですいわばそっちをつけますよね走るでゼロでした本当にも
本当に申し訳ございませんはいあーん
れました弦ああああああ分かりましたすいませんあ者がこういう格好良く屋さんと俺を
ふざけてこんなことやってるわけじゃないんですよ
おはようございますと頑張ってみますしてませんだいとりあえず皆さんあいつでします
母
コンテンツを始めそうですはい強い日がやってまいりました今月はたくさんイベントが
いました
まずはですねどすべてのイベントにですね参加してくださった皆様本当にありがとう
ございます
あのー今日の増加そのイベントな感謝の気持ちせることとちょっと今月の僕の
スケジュールが多分全然のうちで最も激しいと思われるねちょっと
近況報告の動画になりますはいまずはですねイベント
youtube ファンフェストそしてその後になったぶー僕の上昇のイベントも us
そして23日にあったさいたまスーパーアリーナで行ったティーン the
collection に来てくださった皆様本当にありがとうございました本当に皆
さんのネット応援とか線がなければ僕はもうねやってらんないですよ
いややってやれますそれをやりますけどやりますけど本当に皆様の声援がんで僕は何と
かやっております本当にみなさんありがとうございます
いやー
盛り上がってるねはい本当にで会社の方はすごい割上がってとても良かったですどっち
かというとしゃべり家 mc とかそっちの方が多かったのであの
しゃべるのが苦手な僕にとってはとても勉強になるいい機会でした
本当にねそのような機会を与えてくださった皆様に感謝しておりますありがとうござい
ますでここからなんですけど今の俺の状況の
列目に入るとれ前世僕に大きなミッション fujitsu ありまして通帳を記帳し
なければいけなかったんです
もうねこれはね本当にますと通帳の記帳を怠るとですねなんか色々とあの諸問題が起き
てしまうようで
マミーがねーまじで本当にお前まず通帳を記帳するってこと前から前から前からずっと
言ってたんですけどもようやくちょっとねあの静岡でゆっくりできる時間ができた
通帳の記帳に行ったんですけどもそれねもう絶対忘れちゃダメだと思って頑張って覚え
てて銀行には行けたんですよミッションクリアそこは大丈夫だったんですけどもそこに
気を取られ過ぎてて財布を紛失してしまいましたすいませんでした
僕は今
お金がありません東京から静岡に帰ってきてでそのままその乗った
竹丸線がもうそのまま入っちゃったわけですが大阪の方まで新幹線が入っちゃって何年
は僕の財布は新大阪行にあります
笑音や不安だよもうなんか俺でたじゃねターンでやってるわけじゃないですよなんて
ネタで大阪まで最後お届けなきゃいけないですか
いやでも今月俺がんばったよイベントたくさん出たその中でも何かや動画をちょこっと
ばたしてるしもうね財布はせるぐらいのことをやってきたと思ってる
何かを成し遂げるためには何かを失わなければいけないんでまぁその4
凸としては僕の財布が犠牲になったと思っております
で最後の方はですね打ち新大阪駅で新幹線の中で打ち最強見つかったみたいなんで財布
の方も確保されているのでそこ
安心なんですけども新大阪の方から僕日まで郵送されるんで
その届くしばらくの間僕はお金がありませんそこで僕はいち早くお金を手に入れなきゃ
と思って
通常で銀行で
金をおろそうと思ったんですけども2ちゃんはね今色々は計画
10回の方において言って僕に会いまお金をおろすお金を手に入れる手段がありません
という状況の中何と何度ですね
明日からまた東京に行くことになりましたよっ
パパ
バッハ
母
は
東京やばいよ静岡東京静岡時は静岡東京のパターンですよ完全に大です
僕このどこに行けばいいのでは web 住んでるところは関大姫
par
という感じですねちょっと左右はないんですけどもなんとかしてとりあえずここから年
止めて明日東京に行こうかって話になってるんですねまぁ踏圧に連絡したんですけど
友達が今お金5000円しかないって言ってるんで風がそうだとまずいなぁフレーズれ
てそのイベントは一段落したのと本当に来てくださった皆様本当にありがとうござい
ました
そして jr の国の財布を見つけてくださ
また行き員の方本当にありがとうございました免許証保険庁もクレジット全部入って
いるのであれが誰かにとられると僕はもう一ではなくなっていました本当にありがとう
ございました
ここでも全部ないし自分の時間もないんですけども僕は皆さんに支えられて今を生きて
おります
すべての人に感謝して i ターン
フライブ
しています